просто фейк на тему українські
актори ніби інсценує на потрусі
на мирне населення в Україні
продай мені так створджій посольство
Росії у Мадриді у своєму Твіттері
Я все звірств російських скроневих
моїх вимог ти йти У Твіті відео
стало вірусним і набрехала він від Мільйон по
реклядь А лощена з правді показано у
виду але впораються зйомкою фільму
аленепроте простіше каші російський
посольство ті, які займаються сцени
для українського скроневого фільму область
хороїв зйомкою проводилася в порожньому або
ми знаємо кадри тут зйомок А сам ролок
тут немаленького майданчика
продюсер фільму
знімають на фейк акіно від вигляду російського
посольства в Мадриді з входом видали
доки війена в Україні відриваючи на insimo
fronте роскортаєте інформативна вина
Росія носила на національну
міжнародну аудиторію Зате допоможу і
масштабну пропагандистську кампанію Я
як пройти на різних рівнях Давайте
розгляну муки каприкладів для початку на
Російському він державному талабашині в
прайм-тайм депутат російську Думи
Олександр Бородай
створджитальйони
то дуже швидко стає
Росія анатомія дала жодних достовірних
токаїв того ще польський стегня
воюють в Україні всі докозеківані
представили колишні Петрівка ми як Цей
розпочавши то наказ Верховного Генерала
польську армію про мобілізацію кілька
міжнародних вакчекарів зрубав і
виставок ц фотошоп
Російська Пропаганда аж неякість
прямого малюка на теплі води тільки на
російські на
селанев орієнтована на міжнародну
аудиторію Давайте розглядаємо батька та
виражають приклад ц ні в цій виді Так в
ньюс розповідаючи про найкращу ногу біженця
з України та Київ шантажувавши янок Петру
Савченко намистинку шантажувавши десятки ним
Кейн на увазі вин винний опублікувавши
порнографічні зміни
в барах Проте відео неймовірного
біженці фейк викрустальний
стандартам дизайну ДВ можна
помедзаторезничу здобувши на літеру
X
також підозріла їм я Петру Савченко не
знаходити пітоподібних результатів при
котів в інтернеті тварини змії на
повідомила прудкою небатуінцедент все за
таких обстав майже річковий
Федерального управління Кримінальну
політики німчини сказавши нам ще поліції
невидому протоку та випадок
виворотний гармат заражений показуючи на
фотографії зображена інша особливо
видос роблона на професії та Експерт
обожнюючого Але створа російською та
фабрикам та троллів
ми багатою чайники вказують на Кремль
яману вазі можна його не сам Кремль від них
акторів Єгипет трюмович Кремль Кіпру
ють на нього Кримські змії те що
відео загине називається спуффінгом
цикл та цифрова ідентичність підкеровується
воювати
з іншими
прикладом на вигляд схожі на продукцію BBC
він втомився вірусним якщо російського
ракетного обстрілу залізничного вокзалу
Краматорська в Україна
жартую ракету українські війська не в цю
випустила за своєю можна селлоню бібісі
вигляд разу вже замкнула назвав виду
фейком
його в ракетну атаку для BBC петердів
повідомлення невид побачивши дисності
схожа на пробу вибуду в це давіру то
ж насправді канали в кілограм говорити
що ви не довіряєте нам про анелюбут
російські змії вісь BBC звільнити вам те
саме те ж по суті ц Поклик зовні
підтвердження струмків та Києва намагається
пропало це ширше у цій
російської компанії намахаете ви правда
це Хвилина і спадком перець російський
аудиторію, що забрали Захід напавна
сильним
часом
так
виклик у Європі то санкції проти Росії
з аеропортаж російської державної
толебания показує продають банк у
її чинись клієнтів подвоїлася
ще німці пов'язують падіння зливи житія
з
Санкт-Петербурга Росії
інформацію коней зрада Але обидва
вирвану з контексту інуді ваносилку
ніби виходу на це абсурдно
сьогодні ми поговоримо про мікросвіт
дрібних бактеріях коростяних кліщах
блохах і навіть у Шах тема виявляється
адже актуальна освічена Європа
схоже відкочується в Середньовіччя
коли там просто не милися
особиста гігієна була на такому низькому
рівні що всі нестерпно смерділи свербіли
і хворіли на непристойні хвороби
російська пропагандиста зарість Європи
по ширинуються бактерії просто кліщі бліх
і на воще там і наркотичного пацюка
вони на національному рівні вони в даних
Європейського центру профілактики
контролю хвороб ми носа доходом на
адже розпливчастих доказів на Петро ім
кутегу абсурдного твердіння
нам на увазі ми прозоре зрощення в ЄС
паразити особистих кліщів воші та блиг
обману в цій заблуді в цій
маніпулювати ми та пропаганди протягнуті
нас на один бік війни Однак
найбільший цинічно викроїти її провини
адже походи самого президента
у бучі бомбардування по лігві
військових слухань мирних жителів
крута Пропаганда
майшазаема ти це сунневи роз'їдні
маніпулюючи